[Music]
one direction or Harry Styles hit number
one with his first solo album and now
well harry's grouping it he's got some
acting tops too and we have a look
behind the scenes of his first movie
role the 23 year old chopped his
trademark locks for the role of a world
war ii soldier and Dunkirk he auditioned
competing with thousands of other men
know you know pretend there's an
explosion happening over here it's
actually going on and then I think you
know that just means you get natural
reaction stuff Harry joins fellow
newcomers Jack Loudon tumblin Carney and
thin whitehead a 20 year old unknown
hoop before being cast was washing
dishes I was coming out onto the beach
and there was like 1300 extras and those
explosions going off in the same
and the pure panic and terror director
Christopher Nolan you know the guy
behind Christian Bale's Batman and Leos
inception says he hand-picked the cast
to accurately represent the young men
involved in this true story about the
evacuations of soldiers from a ravaged
Beach and France during the war the
traditional thing in Hollywood movies is
to cast 28 29 year-olds 30 year-olds and
pretend they're younger they wanted to
cast people of the right age he's like
the first one the last one to leave this
to second shot in the trailer has the
internet asking does Harry die the
singer gave a hint telling Rolling Stone
quote it was hard man physically really
tough but I love acting I love playing
someone else I'd sleep really well at
night then get up and continue drowning
he paralyzed those 1d fans they wouldn't
be able to handle themselves and you
know if he's looking for more acting
roles while he's certainly living in the
right place here in LA yeah and that's
he's moving real estate the 23 year old
recently listed his West Hollywood
mansion for Oh about eight and a half
million dollars cool eight and a half
million
you